mais
lyon mais stéphanie habite ce duplex
depuis 2014 après trois ans de
rénovation majeurs ils peuvent enfin
profiter des petits bonheurs de la vie
mais le 6 août dernier une mauvaise
surprise les attendait à leur réveil la
première qu'on a vu c'est et c'est ici
s'est propagée sloat main s'est répandue
sur le mur mitoyen de vaud mâchon la
sécheresse des derniers mois a causé
l'affaissement d'une partie de la
structure de leurs duplex plus le temps
passait plus on voyait des sort tous les
jours apparaître tous les jours en fait
- d'où les steaks ont fait
c'est la folie présentement avec la
sécheresse des sols ça crée des
situations qui sont problématiques
dans la région métropolitaine le sol est
argileux il ya urgence cette entreprise
spécialisée reçoit présentement trois
fois plus d'appels qu'en temps normal
concernant des problèmes de fondation
l'ensemble des régions métropolitaines
est affecté c'est sûr qu'il ya des
endroits où ce que c'est plus est plus
marquée en référence à l'est de l'île de
montréal ici il s'agit d'une
construction qui date de 1959 et travaux
sont majeurs tout comme les dégâts il
faut comprendre que l'affaissement c'est
un problème qui est
nécessairement bâtiment c'est lié aux
soldes en dessous du bâtiment
si les prédispositions à un affaissement
ça va arriver la plupart des assurances
ne couvrent pas ce type de travaux les
propriétaires se retrouve donc avec une
facture de plusieurs milliers de dollars
un bon galop
de taille normale c'est des travaux qui
peuvent coûter entre 45 et 55 mille
dollars
et le coût de la matière première ne
cesse d'augmenter elle a su ce soir qui
représente une bonne proportion de du
coup deux contre un salaire doublé
depuis l'année passée la ville de
montréal a mis sur pied en février un
programme de subventions pour aider les
propriétaires effectuent des travaux de
rénovation relie au changement
climatique
le programme a dû être fermé en juillet
dernier la raison il y a eu trop
d'inscription en cinq mois la ville a
reçu 1102 demande ce qui représente des
subventions de plus de 9 millions de
dollars soit le double de ce qui était
initialement prévu
lyon mais stéphanie ne savent pas s'ils
pourront bénéficier de ce programme pour
l'instant ce sont leurs économies qui
payeront les travaux qui doivent
commencer en novembre pour un saint
c'est un cauchemar c'est du stress que
logique du véhicule quand on coupe à
travers ta famille ton travail les
percussions sont énormes devant
l'urgence de la situation ils ont rédigé
une pétition où ils interpellent les
élus municipaux à se prononcer
clairement sur cet enjeu qui risque
d'être de plus en plus fréquent qu'on
veuille pas pour moi mais pour
l'ensemble des citoyens et ne rendent le
qu'est ce que vous allez faire quels
seront vos mesures préventives contre et
l'assèchement des sols
la ville confirme que le programme sera
à nouveau disponible mais à compter de
janvier 2022